laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
it can be hard knowing what to practice
when you're first starting off with your
flow Journey but I'm here to help with
another 10 tricks that you should
definitely line up sooner rather than
later Drex here from drexfactor POI
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm coming at
you with a sequel to that list of the 10
POI tricks that you should start with
and giving you 10 more but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca becklinen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
so let's be real here starting off your
POI Journey can be a little bit of a
challenge not just because you're having
to learn some brand new skills but also
because there isn't really what we would
call An established order or Canon of
the tricks as you're supposed to go
through them I've been teaching POI now
for a decade and a half and in that time
I've definitely been keeping notes on
which tricks flow into each other and
which skills are necessary for things
down the road so I've been putting
together my own Canon list of the order
that those POI tricks ought to go in in
fact I already shared 10 of them let's
do a quick summary right now pendulums
extensions boy butterflies reels or real
turns stalls windmills inspin flowers
tuck turns the three beat weave waist
wraps now after I published that list I
got so many requests from people that
wanted to know the next 10 tricks in
order so your wish is my command I did
my best to assemble a list of 10 tricks
that are essential at the beginning and
that technically speaking you can get
down if you haven't gotten down the
tricks that were on the first list but
if you did get down all the tricks on
the first list it is going to come in
super handy for this list so without
further Ado let's go ahead and dive in
I'm going to start you off with two
different butterfly variations
trick number one thread the needle
personally I've always loved thread the
needle both because it's a great
challenge for balancing out what each of
your hands is capable of as well as the
fact that it makes for some really cool
accents there's a really dramatic
presentation of thread the needle that
involves moving your hands really far
back and forth as you're performing the
trick I think that this can look really
percussive and a great accompaniment to
POI dance it's also a great trick to
give to people who are struggling to
even out the proficiency of each of
their hands usually our dominant hand
starts off being able to do pretty much
anything we can think of but our
non-dominant hand might struggle to
catch up with it but baked in a thread
the needle is evening at the proficiency
of each of our hands being the dominant
one in performing a butterfly literally
all thread the needle is is switching
off which hand is the dominant one and
of course buried within thread the
needle is a great lesson on POI cross
points that is moving the POI back and
forth between parallel planes if you're
interested in learning more about that I
will go ahead and link to a video that I
recently did on that topic down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you're watching on YouTube
split time butterflies
okay now we're getting wild with our
butterflies out there the theory behind
split time butterflies is pretty simple
we're just performing a butterfly but
we've changed the timing of it from
being in together time to being split
time so the POI meet together to either
side and they're split apart top and
bottom and I must say I've always loved
split time butterflies because they seem
so at odds with the symmetry of human
anatomy like when we do our together
time butterflies we are fundamentally
working with something that is a mirror
image across itself on a vertical line
whereas when we do our split time
butterflies it's a mirror image across a
horizontal line and that feels very
strange to human beings but honestly I
tend to find that my favorite variation
on most POI tricks involves using split
time butterflies so it's best to start
with this as early as possible to really
get it into your body awesome so for
these next four tricks we're going to be
digging a little bit into the world of
reels and weaves that we covered in the
first video so if you're not caught up
on those might be a good idea to do so
before going any further
trick number three hip reels
wait a second though didn't we cover
reels in the first video yes and we
covered one specific type of reel in the
first video but now I want to come at it
from a more systematic fashion see reels
are something that we can keep fixed
around specific parts of our bodies in
this case I want us to focus on the hips
not only can we keep the reels fixed
around that part of our body but we can
also move the POI in one of four
different variations that we refer to as
timing and Direction timing and
direction is one of the most important
Concepts in POI and it generally means
that any trick you learn is going to
have four variations associated with it
if you are unfamiliar with timing and
direction again I will go ahead and
leave a link to a video on that topic
down in the description as well as up in
the cards if you're watching on YouTube
but once we understand what we're
capable of we can play around with our
hip reels in together same we can play
around with them in together opposite we
can play around with them in Split Time
same direction and we can play around
with them in Split time opposites which
is an entire Venture in and of itself
and as with most things POI if there's a
version of this that works around our
lower half there's also a version that
works around our upper half too
trick number four shoulder reels
cool so the theory here is actually
pretty similar to what it was with our
hip reels namely we're trying to focus
on having our POI reels concentrated
around a single part of the body in this
case rather than our hips it's going to
be our shoulders and of course just like
our hip rails we want to try and work
through each and every one of our
shoulder reels and all of the different
timing Direction modes together same
together opposite
split Time same direction and split time
opposites which once again is a bit of
an adventure and the eagle-eyed among
you may have also picked up on the fact
that we actually already learned one of
these in the first list video namely
those windmills are pretty much the same
thing as shoulder reels done in Split
Time same direction pretty cool huh one
of the greatest things you can get out
of drilling both your hip reels and your
shoulder reels is the ability to go back
and forth between them and play around
with your levels as you're spinning your
POI this also leads directly to things
like tuck turns and a whole variety of
other things like body tracers as well
and it also mashes up with the weaves
from our first list video to produce
number five fountains
so yes I know that this move got passing
mention in the last video but I do
actually want to expand on that just a
little bit here fountains occur when we
take a waist strap that is turning back
and forth between a forwards and reverse
three beat weave and suddenly adding up
and down motion to it this effectively
turns that waist wrap into something
more akin to a flower and this actually
winds up being really important
knowledge for a lot of poi tricks in the
future that ability to kind of smush
down something that's got a lot of
volume to it to just a straight line
whether it be a horizontal line or a
vertical line comes in really handy for
understanding the relationships between
a whole bunch of other POI moves add to
that the fact that it gives your waist
straps some level changes which I am
always a fan of yeah I think that this
is well worth adding to your repertoire
and of course it leads directly into
another slightly more stripped down
version of this trick called
trick number six the four beat fountain
the 4B Fountain is always going to have
a special place in my heart because it
was really the first POI move that I
learned that was two different POI moves
that had been kind of cut and pasted
together thus showing me the potential
for transitioning between different
point moves not only does the four beat
fountain look really cool but it's also
a great example of how we can create
interesting POI transitions by cutting
and pasting different point moves in
different orders I love going from this
waist wrap up into a shoulder reel in
Split Time same direction or Windmill
and feeling what happens and what
changes when I make all these changes in
the movement of the POI I also recently
discovered that there are two variations
on this depending upon how involved you
want to get with the movement of your
hands there's a version of this that
involves passing your hands in front of
your face during the top part of the
fountain and another version that
involves trying to keep your hands back
behind your ears until the POI are ready
to come out in front of you you can
think of this as the difference between
moving your hands back and forth across
your body twice versus just once with
the hands in front on bottom and behind
on top with one variation and then
moving back and forth between the two
several times in the other cool so next
up we're going to take a look at two
poemus that utilize horizontal planes
rather than vertical ones
trick number seven corkscrews
so I'm just going to say up front that
corkscrews are awesome and they are one
of the most versatile POI tricks that
you can possibly do that involve working
on a horizontal plane for the longest
time corkscrews were the only POI tricks
that I knew of that worked on a
horizontal plane many people
accidentally do them when they're trying
to do windmills instead and wind up just
somewhere with their planes a little bit
flopped over but corkscrews are good for
so much more than that corkscrews are a
great tool to dance with they're also a
great way of transitioning in and out of
a variety of other horizontal plane
moves and well they look pretty cool in
their own right one of my favorite
variations is a four beat version which
we're going to save for a little further
down the road if you all don't mind and
of course I love playing around with
different amounts of volume as I'm
performing these corkscrews going big
with them going small and everywhere in
between there is so much versatility
here if you know what to look for and
speaking of horizontal plane moves that
do not get nearly enough credit
trick number eight horizontal plain
flowers
so ironically enough a lot of us
actually do this trick unintentionally
when we are very early on in our POI
Journey it is after all much easier to
keep those POI just hanging below our
hands than it is to try and get them
spinning up in vertical planes which is
fine but I also think that there's a lot
of potential here that sometimes doesn't
get explored until much later in our POI
Journey horizontal flowers represent a
great opportunity for us to play around
with turning back and forth across our
body we can also take our time adding
and removing petals depending upon how
fast we want to go through that turn and
in the process learn a lot more about
how we can move through a space also has
to be said they represent a great
opportunity to switch back and forth
between the vertical flowers we talked
about in our last video and the
horizontal flowers that we're talking
about right now
I'm a fan of transitions aren't you I
swear horizontal flowers are something
of a Rosetta Stone you're able to use
them not just to switch back and forth
between vertical flowers and horizontal
ones but also they're really helpful for
moving into corkscrews in a variety of
other horizontal plane moves as well
these really are an incredibly useful
tool cool so we're zeroing in on our
last two moves and for these we're going
to be focusing specifically on
transition tools namely stalls
trick number nine up stalls
so straight up and yes pun intended up
stalls were the first POI trick that I
ever saw that truly took my breath away
that truly looked like a moment when the
laws of physics were glitching out just
having a single POI head sticking up
towards the ceiling and staying there
for a half a second
mind-blowing there are also some super
important lessons that come from
learning up stalls that also help out
with learning things like top stalls
isolations and a variety of other POI
tricks down the road this is also
another one of those POI tricks that it
is super helpful to drill in a really
systematized fashion that is once you've
got a good understanding of timing and
Direction be sure that you can do up
stalls with your hands moving in every
single mode you'll discover as you do
this that up stalls are a great
transition tool for getting into spaces
that you couldn't otherwise access with
just your down stalls this gives you
access to more Transitions and
transitions are always a good thing and
of course they are super necessary for
our last trick on the list now before I
reveal to you what that trick is if you
come as far it must mean that you like
POI tricks a lot which the good news is
I produce a lot of content about POI and
POI tricks so if you could please leave
me a like And subscribe to the channel
so you get to check out all of my POI
videos as I upload them it'll be good
for both you and for me thanks in
advance and now without further Ado the
last trick on this list
trick number 10 stall splits
okay so what exactly is this that I'm
demonstrating here well basically it is
taking any kind of poi movement where I
have the POI spinning in Split time
whether it be split Time same direction
or split time opposites and I'm
performing both a down stall and an up
stall at the same time this produces
this glorious appearance where I have
one POI appearing to completely defy the
laws of gravity and the other one moving
in stark contrast to it this can happen
either with the POI apart or the POI
together depending upon what timing and
Direction mode I'm in now I kind of
struggle with putting this one on the
list because it's not usually thought of
as being a discrete trick in and of
itself and yet at the same time there is
so much really important knowledge that
is buried inside of it not only does
this give you practice at performing two
very different types of stalls at the
same time which is going to be really
really helpful in a variety of other
tricks down the road not to mention
transitions but also if you perform the
variation of this that that happens in
Split Time same direction the only way
you can do it is by getting down a skill
that I like to call the lanes of poi
that is being able to hold one POI
closer to your body than the other so
they don't tangle up
this is knowledge that is incredibly
important plus which I have to admit
that when I learned how to do this
myself I practiced it never endingly and
I just thought the appearance of it was
cool in itself it didn't really have a
name as a trick and that's why I'm
giving it one right now but it was still
something that I felt proud of as a
neophyte POI spinner and I hope if you
take on this challenge you'll be proud
of it too so there you go that was my
list of the next 10 POI tricks that you
should pick up in your POI Journey what
did you think of my list were there
things that you think should have made
the list and didn't things that did make
the list that you're kind of not sure
about leave me a comment and let me know
and if you'd like more structured
tutorials on how to perform any and all
these tricks I would highly recommend my
beginner POI course over on mylearning
site at learn.drexfactor.com even better
if you watch this video and you'd like
to take the plunge I'm going to give you
a cool little deal on it too if you use
the code second 10 that is 2 ND 10 the
number 10 you can can get a discount of
five percent off the cost of the entire
course so go check that out please and
thank you
[Music]
this video would not be possible we're
not for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently a
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor POI and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards but even better
than that you will be helping me out in
my mission to create videos just like
this one and sending them out in the
world to educate people about POI
spinning and flow Arts so go check that
out please and thank you if you'd like
to check out a tutorial series that I
did covering these and some other
beginner tricks I will go ahead and
leave a link to that down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here because it's
really popular amongst people that are
frequenting my channel so maybe give
that a look as well thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon
peace